hi i'm keenan crane i'm a geometer and
professor of computer science at
carnegie mellon university and today
i've been asked to explain fractals at
five levels of increasing complexity so
fractals are a sort of strange kind of
shape that have detail at all different
levels fractals appear all over nature
they rise naturally in computer graphics
because we want to make beautiful images
of the natural world fractals are also
really interesting because they show how
extremely simple descriptions can give
rise to really complex shapes
what's your name myra have you heard of
fractals before
um no absolutely not so a fractal is
something that we see every day but it's
a little bit hard to describe it's it's
a shape that if you look at it really
far away or you look at it really up
close
it has kind of a similar appearance and
actually that word fractal sounds a
little bit like fraction right
so actually fractals are in some way
fractions but for shapes have you ever
seen a movie called moana yes yeah moana
lives on this like beautiful island
right this island has lots of trees on
it some artists had to make all those
trees how do you think they do that
they um try to
find something similar to that
on the google and
they try to picture it in their head
saying what would what would it look
like if they it was animated so somehow
they have to explain to the computer
what a tree looks like so that the
computer can draw the tree for them yes
and that's kind of what we're gonna try
out today in fact we're gonna have you
build a fractal a tree is a really good
example of a fractal because if you look
at the whole tree and then you break off
a big branch of the tree yes it almost
looks like that branch that you broke
off is itself another tree so our rule
is that every branch splits into two
smaller branches okay
so your tree is totally beautiful but it
took a long time to make right how would
you feel if i said now you have to make
a thousand of those trees i'd be like oh
my that's a lot of work yeah it's a ton
of work if you think about
moana's island it has these tens and
hundreds of thousands of trees on it and
that's why we need computers to help us
out because computers are really good at
taking these really simple rules like
put two branches on every other branch
and doing it really really fast i want
to know how to draw a fractal on a
computer if you want to learn to draw
fractals then you might need to learn a
little bit about programming programming
like coding like coding exactly that's
what actually a lot of the artists for
the movies are working with code rather
than with a paintbrush
so in your own words how would you
describe a fractal to somebody i would
describe a fractal by saying that when
you see a object
if you'll zoom in closely you'll see
that it's it's broken down into pieces
so as you zoom in more closely you'll
keep seeing
smaller and smaller pieces
definitely that is totally what fractals
are all about yes
what are you studying in seventh grade
these days i think we're doing
geometry so what if i told you that
there are shapes
where
you can't measure
the length of the perimeter it's big but
um
all of the sides are kind of like
so
weird that they wouldn't be able to
pinpoint anything specific to add
together the shape is just super super
complicated and so you can't actually
measure the length yeah right yeah so
that's already a really good
idea of what a fractal is it has some
really really interesting detail at all
scales that makes it hard to talk about
standard quantities like lengths and
areas and volumes would a
planet or an asteroid be a fractal
yeah so if you look at kind of the
wrinkly surface of an asteroid each one
of those little wrinkles adds a little
bit to the surface area and so it's
really hard to say what is the area of
an asteroid let's take a look at a
little example of where fractals
actually show up in nature
what we're going to try to do is we're
going to try to say what the length of
the coastline of great britain is so
we're going to start out with the blue
ones which are spaced further apart
we're going to ask you to connect the
blue pins with a piece of string so we
can get a measurement of the coastline
so we have our first measurement of the
length of the coastline and we're going
to do it over again but this time we're
going to use the white pins which are
spaced closer together
so we measured the coastline again and
what do you think happens there's more
in and out therefore probably takes more
strength for this one i think i agree
with you but i think to really validate
our scientific experiment we should
probably
compare the length of the string
a lot of extra slack in that ping string
so what we noticed with great britain is
we were never able to measure its length
it just kept getting longer and longer
this is called the coastline paradox
where
there's not really one definite number
you can assign to the length of the
coastline but it depends on how you
measure it like if we kept going
to really get this to be accurate we
might have to like actually go down the
beach and start measuring these tiny
little details along the coastline but
really there's so much detail we would
probably never get a definite answer for
how long the coastline is fractals also
give us a really nice language we're
talking about how smooth or rough some
kind of shape is and actually a lot of
people engineers and scientists use this
idea of fractals in this language of
fractals to compare different shapes not
in terms of their size but in terms of
their roughness so based on everything
we talked about today how would you
describe a fractal to somebody in your
own words it's a shape
that
you can't describe as a shape yeah
totally like it's a shape that you can't
use sort of the ordinary language that
we use to talk about shapes you really
need some other ideas or concepts to
talk about
[Music]
do you play any video games um i really
like hearthstone minecraft what happens
in minecraft if you get really really
close to a shape well it just looks like
a block yeah it looks really blocky and
it's the same thing not only with shapes
and games but also colors and textures
and this is an especially big problem in
virtual reality because you have no
control over where people are going to
go what they're going to look at how
close they're going to get to various
objects so fractals on the other hand
are these things that have
infinitely
you know nice detail as you get closer
and closer and closer and so this is
something that can help us
solve this problem in computer graphics
of generating more detail one of the
reasons why fractals are really nice for
computer graphics is because the
algorithms that we use to draw images
also have this kind of recursive flavor
what's recursion recursion is a function
that uses itself or calls itself in its
definition and basically with that you
can figure out my new details such as
searching for a value in a binary tree
it's kind of like iterating through
itself but it's often more sophisticated
in that it's easier to write they're
easy for a computer to execute right it
just has to run this recursive procedure
over and over and over again we can kind
of get as much detail as we want or need
when i think about fractals and kind of
what they've done for computer graphics
the example i think is
subdivision surfaces did you did you
encounter subdivision surfaces in your
graphics class at um the name doesn't
really ring a bell so subdivision
surface is a way of describing a smooth
shape on a computer rather than some
complicated fractal shape so meshes and
computer graphics are usually made of
these flat polygons with kind of sharp
edges and so the question is how can i
get something nice and round and smooth
out of these sharp looking polygons what
i can do is i can start cutting one at a
time the corners
of this paper off it still looks very
angular i still have these really sharp
points right why are we doing this
because i want to draw a smooth curve on
the screen but all my computer can do is
draw straight lines and that's actually
too true of gpus it's kind of
interesting gpus are basically really
fast machines that can only draw one
thing and that's a flat triangle and so
if we keep doing this with our paper you
kind of get pretty quickly the idea
what's going to happen so when you go to
see a pixar movie for instance every
surface has been subdivided down so you
have tiny little triangles called micro
polygons that are even smaller than the
size of a pixel how long does this
process take well because people really
need to use these uh subdivision
services for everything people worked
hard over the years to make this super
super fast in fact subdivision services
were invented basically at pixar there's
this guy ed catmull and he was partially
responsible for one of the most famous
kinds of subdivision surfaces called
catmo clark subdivision services and in
fact recently won the turing award for
these subdivision services what do you
think are the current shortcomings in i
guess applying fractals to computer
science right now what is what is the
cutting edge so we've talked a little
bit about the positive features of
fractals and procedural graphics which
is you can write one simple recursive
program and the computer creates a lot
of detail for you so that's really nice
right it's saving you a lot of work but
the downside is you lose a lot of
control so because the only thing you're
describing is this short little program
you don't have complete control over how
this is going to end up
and so adding more controllability to
procedural graphics is something people
have been thinking about for many years
so
how has our conversation changed your
understanding of what fractals are all
about i think it's really interesting to
see the different ways fractals will be
not only useful but necessary in being
able to render these games and these
different programs that are interesting
in the metaverse or different
media to be really beautiful
[Music]
hey thanks for joining us remotely yeah
of course it's a pleasure i'm happy to
be here
do you have any sense of how you would
give a really precise mathematical
definition to you know what is a fractal
it would probably have to be some kind
of recursive definition like imaginary
numbers i know the mandelbrot said we'll
use those the mandelbrot set or the
julia set you know the idea is always oh
i'm going to apply some polynomial over
and over again z squared plus c or
something like that when i think about
fractals i try to get away from these
very specific examples and ask what is
it fundamentally that makes a fractal of
fractal and one thing that i think you
can be precise about even if you can't
really say exactly what a fractal is is
you can talk about this idea of fractal
dimension have you ever heard of that no
i have not actually so if you look at
this this piece of paper
what would you say the dimension is well
on the on the paper itself i would say
it's two dimensional but the actual
paper would be
three dimensions because it has a very
small thickness yeah great so so the
real physical paper has some amount of
thickness but when we model this
mathematically we might ignore the
thickness and say yeah this is really
just kind of a two-dimensional sheet of
paper and then you have your apple how
many dimensions is the apple i would
also say three and y three because it
has the height and the width and uh
there's a depth to it as well totally
now as a little experiment take your
piece of paper and just crumple it
into a ball so what is it is the paper
three-dimensional or is it
two-dimensional it changed in dimensions
depending on how it is shaped so it's
not quite as solid as the apple but it's
also not quite as
two-dimensional as the original sheet of
paper and so for this reason
people associate this crumpled ball with
a fractal dimension maybe something like
2.5 dimensions instead of two or three
there are a lot of different definitions
precise definitions of fractal dimension
but i think the one that's easiest to
understand is this thing called box
counting dimension you have let's say an
image and you want to decide what's the
fractal dimension of this image so what
you're going to do is you're going to
count the number of boxes or you can
imagine big pixels of this image that
cover the boundary of this shape and
you're going to see how does that
counting compare with
how the counts work for just an ordinary
shape so so if i have a straight line
and i start out with one big box that
covers the whole line and now i shrink
my boxes by a factor of two i just make
boxes half as big how many boxes will i
need to cover that line
and if i cut that box in half again how
many boxes do i need to cover the line a
four but if you take a more interesting
shape some kind of fractal shape like
let's say the coastline of great britain
and you start doing this box counting
experiment something really interesting
happens as you make these boxes smaller
the number of boxes you need to cover
the coastline grows faster than it would
for just a straight line yeah i've i've
heard about that where
if you if you change the amount of
measurements that for a coastline you
can actually change like how much of the
coast that there is but if you measure
in mile lengths you're going to get a
much
different estimate than if you measure
in one inch increments and so what this
box counting is getting at is saying
well
i still can never decide what the length
of the coastline is but what i can do is
i can see how quick does the number of
boxes grow
relative to how it would grow just for
an ordinary one-dimensional curve like a
line or a circle is there any other
interesting applications of fractals so
procedural computer graphics
which kind of came out of thinking about
fractals is one answer to this question
about how do you add more detail without
for instance consuming tons of memory or
requiring artists to paint ultra
detailed textures so if if you can
instead describe at least some aspect of
what you're looking at in a procedural
or recursive way then you can add as
much detail as you need when you get
close to objects do you mean like perlin
noise yeah like perlin noise is a great
example right perlin noise was one of
the early ways of synthesizing
additional texture at any level of
detail that you needed to make things
look natural and realistic i have a
random question do you know how the
research into fractals began
you can look pretty far back in history
to see kind of
glimmers of this idea of fractals in
science in the 19th century people were
trying to look for examples of things in
mathematics that were very unnatural so
there was for instance this guy named
georg cantor who was showing that you
can have these sets with really strange
properties or you can have functions
with really strange properties this
thing called the devil's staircase and
so on and it wasn't until about a
century later where
someone named mandelbrot said oh
actually this strange mathematics that
was meant to show how unnatural things
can happen is actually a perfect
description of things that really do
happen in nature and from there people
really ran with it and said oh okay well
if these
fractal descriptions are good for nature
we can also use that for creating really
realistic and believable pictures in
computer graphics
[Music]
i can say that when you reached out to
me
and i first learned about this program i
immediately went to my computer and i
implemented yet another version of like
zooming into the mandelbrot set yeah
just because i was so excited you know
so that the thing is that it took me
maybe 30 minutes a kid at home who's
like 13 and 14 who just starts playing
around with a simple computer program
can make incredibly beautiful fractals
yeah and i think that's one of the
things that's exciting about it or you
don't even need computers like i
remember when i was a kid i played
electric guitar and i had all these
guitar pedals with different effects and
oh what happens if you put the output
back in the input and just run it
through itself you're going to start
hearing this kind of fractal sound right
so today we've been telling people
fractals are things that are somehow
self-similar they have detail at all
scales are there other ways you might
introduce fractals to somebody or are
there other things you might say this is
what a fractal is i think you could get
to the reasons why does a coastline look
like a coastline at all different scales
it's because the forces of nature tend
to work similarly at all different
scales and it's those
forces that
are doing very very simple things over
and over and over again that are
constantly creating the sense of detail
i think about like the scale and
variance of different physical equations
like navier stokes is you know kind of
scale invert you know this reynolds
number that tells you how viscous things
are but you can have the same kind of
fluid behavior at all different scales
and that's why you get turbulence at all
different scales i actually actually
remember the moment when i finally
figured out how to make turbulence in
computer graphics i was working for this
company magi and disney was working on a
movie i think it was weird science where
they wanted to have a marble vaz and
then about three in the morning i was at
a diner nearby and i was pouring the
cream into the coffee and i was watching
it and i started watching it swirl
around and i realized that what was
happening was really simple the you had
this line of cream and then it hits the
cup and it folds and then the folds get
caught up and then that folds again and
it's a really simple process of folding
within folding and i just went to the
computer and did that yeah and things
look like marble and look like flame and
they look like clouds and they look like
you just keep using those simple
techniques yeah and i think it's really
cool that this kind of fractal
description of geometry or physics is
also kind of baked into the nature of
computation computation is recursive
kind of by its nature and so it's kind
of a match made in heaven that we happen
to build these machines that also right
you know behave the way that you just
have to understand recursion exactly
somebody once told me in order to
understand recursion you just have to
understand recursion
there you go and then you get it all
yeah but i think it's this point that
that point with the coffee is important
because the forces were operating at one
scale they were operating at the scale
of the coffee cup but over time they
kept making details are smaller and
smaller process at one scale plus time
you get fractals i think that's also
what's so beautiful about fractals is
that you know if you think about sort of
the history of geometry as well felix
klein
was looking at geometry by saying well
geometry is all about invariance i have
some group of transformations and i look
at objects that are sort of invariant
with respect to these transformations so
if you just look at translations okay
what kinds of shapes remain the same
under translations well you get tiling
you get wallpaper and if you start
asking that same question what if i
allow scaling in my transformations then
boom you have fractals immediately come
out of nowhere and everybody understands
scaling scaling is a simple thing yeah
now you work on kind of the future of
virtual reality and augmented reality
and extended reality but it's kind of
interesting because i think if i think
about exploring these infinite fractal
landscapes in some way they still feel a
little bit
lonely or they feel a little bit poor of
the kind of richness that we have in the
real world this is where uh machine
learning um starts coming in because you
can start saying okay this is a very
very rich virtual world but it's
informed by you know my favorite
mountains that i saw in italy once so
you can start training these fractal
worlds on things about the real world
that have particular emotional resonance
for us people outside of computer
graphics and engineering and science and
so forth have also thought a lot about
and used fractals as a language for
talking about nature for characterizing
shapes and behaviors and so forth tissue
or friction or all sorts of really
important phenomena
do you think that computer graphics has
kind of dropped the ball in terms of
saying you know this is not something
that's exciting anymore to work on
procedural uh descriptions and we're
moving on from that well i mean if you
look at any hollywood movie or you look
at any of the game worlds that people
are spending all their time in they're
highly procedural they have to be and
they have to make use of fractal
techniques because it's basically a way
to get enormous complexity without
having to explicitly store the
complexity and because they're able to
use these relatively simple fractal
techniques to make very complex looking
natural things right lazy evaluation we
love being lazy in computer graphics
well it's also it's not even possible to
explore to store an entire world in your
computer absolutely you want to be able
to sort of generate it on the fly i'm
looking forward to things getting better
we're not there yet so one of the things
i guess that touches on is this question
about controllability or the ease of
with which everybody can create these
worlds not just people not just
mathematicians not just you know trained
computer scientists one thing when i
think about ken muskraves working about
this program bryce this one i felt like
i could really use what do you think we
still need to do in terms of putting
these kinds of tools in in people's
hands making it easier for people to use
proceduralism machine learning to build
these kind of worlds i think in that
case it came down to the fact that ken
in particular had a mission to
make accessible tools for people without
sacrificing the power and the richness
of making beautiful things i mean in a
sense he was kind of the computer
graphic
bob ross
so he made the land of happy little
trees yeah yeah which i mean when you
when you think about the techniques of
somebody like a bob ross um they're
fractal yeah i think this is what what's
so beautiful also about mandelbrot's
work is him saying you know it's not
really about these exotic examples like
even the mandelbrot set or julia sets or
whatever yeah they're like really
interesting mathematical curiosities but
they get at this idea that fractals are
kind of inevitable and bob ross probably
never as far as i know never sat down
and you know thought about recursive
descriptions of trees or anything like
that but it's just something that
naturally comes to you as an artist well
i mean you can go back to all the
classic artists vinci's notebooks were
just full of like this thing looks like
that thing at completely different
scales so he didn't have a fancy word
for it but he completely understood it
yeah it's really part of human nature or
humans connection to nature yeah
hopefully our discussion today has
helped you see the world in a different
way and also see how mathematics and art
can come together to make beautiful
images i hope it's inspired you to look
at the world around you in a different
way